just switch lanes I was at the Long
Beach aquarium and some dad told another
dad to get his son cuz he kept squirting
people I said there's if you want a sure
way to get in a fight correct someone
else's kid on parenting or a painting on
parenting and it's [ __ ] on man
like fisticuffs weird I just settled
these two down yeah you did yeah because
it's this kid was squirting other
parents and I think that means kids it's
hot as [ __ ] outside you were in the line
of fire of the water and this guy Turner
goes brawl the dad goes did you just
call my son bro you serious right now oh
no you think no dude dude is just call
my son dude and then they've got into it
called was a kid six or seven take it
easy
but there's one way you want to get a
fight till someone about parenting is
ratchet correct my son my school said
hey dude and this mom goes how hetero of
your son how hetero of him she was dude
how hetero you know I just said shut up
it yeah exactly what the [ __ ] are you
talking about British a dog really makes
me angry my wife asked me if I wasn't
there
my wife cuz I'm glad you weren't there I
said yeah you are cuz I would have said
some [ __ ] oh my god get your [ __ ]
ideology out of my [ __ ] face that's
crazy man yeah don't [ __ ] judge my
kid and make him feel weird for saying
something nice to your son you asked
what do you say just what's up dating
tell me hey what's up dude he said hey
dude
do what that's what we're dealing with
okay
yeah that's one party so dumb
well you hit as a kid when you yeah
we're at a place like slapped my mom
slapped your mama your dad want a belt
in the riding crop to the legs that's
all it's good by the way do I deserved
it mm-hm
okay weird love people do the my dad
never had me yeah my mom was like I
can't pull funny I remember I realized
my brother's crazy because my dad didn't
meet start laughing one of us is crazy
maybe every try dad pop I remember my
mom came home after one time smacking my
brother and her hand hurt
she was Peter this before their door she
goes I don't what to do I hit him he
laughs I can't him are enough
laughs it off he knows what he's doing
this isn't working
it's not [ __ ] working my brother's
just smiling like you psycho bro yeah
cuz that [ __ ] hurts well you would do it
because you're more say would go oh
you're gonna hit me you think that's
gonna work well I'm gonna pretend like
it feels good at McDonald's this
everywhere oh my god
have you seen this for having god I was
just big woman get her hands on you
I would pay money to see her wring your
neck like this girl watch this a big
strong girl what did you think that did
you think that the visage in Las Vegas
the boy I thought was gonna be in Hawaii
sorry sorry it looks like bro why Hawaii
look at the girls Samoan I don't really
I'm not like Hawaiian I thought it penal
beam up a small girl this is Vegas this
is Vegas
McDonald's although they look they look
Hawaiian they're big girls no I just
know I'm technically I don't so there's
not TMZ you better be ready boy
oh she just tosses around the table and
knock the coworkers trying to break it
up all right
that little girls these tumors are these
the other ones I'm pulling out she's
trying to attack the co-worker that's
trying to break it up
oh damn now they're going at it oh damn
look at these this holy [ __ ] that girl's
gained her she hammered her something
and tits popping out
she must be hammer some let me ask you
this is the girl that woman works here
right the big girl oh look at this you
grab the chair is the other sister in
DDT or something I feel like that chairs
not gonna hurt her you better get a gun
girl and put your ass cheeks away so
this is a ride around at where it ends
but so the girl that customer for
whatever reason was cussing at the the
big girl and then saying call her big
fat whatever big fat ass whatever and
then at one point she tried to steal
soda from the soda fountain by using a
little water cup then she try to sneak
it by that girl who has so she's like
you can't do that and that's when I
started to eat
though she kept going at another big
girl came to I say wow that girl has
some fight in there oh yeah these are
the girls here I looked into it so does
anything that's that girl
this is a customer yes she is yeah
now that I know anything about it uh the
one on the right is the McDonald's
worker and then where's the other one I
don't think I don't want just the two
main ones so this is the one that was
the customer classy lady and she got her
ass beat
yeah those big girls threw her around
like a [ __ ] ding dong correct like a
ding oh she's this girl kind of started
she threw a mighty nice face gal in
Vegas like that yeah so let the girl get
her [ __ ] mr. pep like this let her
get her mr. pep and broke don't hate on
her III want to leave America sometimes
I'm just talk crazy about my after that
just the culture of America does make
you feel good about yourself all the way
around sometime
I'm just like not go to Texas bro I like
text you get to Texas you like he's back
in the day we did a live fighter in a
kid in Denver and it was in the
outskirts of Denver oh yeah and I had to
come get you and I'll come get you in NJ
and I was sliding all over the [ __ ]
place slidin slip-sliding away crazy
didn't we need you're pretty crazy oh
yeah I was like what does client guys
black ice gots to watch out for the
black ice bro I said you know racist
yeah he's a white ice begins this is
okay chin you've been around snow much I
flipped on a black ice you did in Big
Bear you flipped flipped my buddy's
truck we're going downhill yeah we're
going down no for like not even fast
like 15 miles per hour then there's a
turn he turned the wheel and we're still
going straight and we're like what's
gonna happen hit the wall flipped
flipped on top the windshield crushed on
us
I thought we're gonna get smashed to
death and then it stopped and then we
started sliding down the mountain
my buddy don't one up his story brah
oh hey Trump's how about you right but
did you did you get hurt one of our
friends did get hurt he got thrown out
of the truck five yeah he wasn't wearing
a seat belt
how leap he had his back injured sleep
and then he was in the emergency room
and we had like a cop come down get us
back up the mountain to the emergency
room so he was getting checked out no
injuries no but my friend lost his shoes
in the snow with court like glass
everywhere and a bunch of cars that came
to that same area they started sliding
hit the car another one hit the car
house it's crazy man can you be no my
buddy flipped his 19 years not Honda
Civic and he goes and he was acidic oh
hey whoa boom flipped it right over on
his back and he got out and he was like
ah
dude it was [ __ ] crazy my Taekwondo
teacher same kind of thing I in the snow
boom boom boom he gets out car hits him
oh no you know it sends him flying my
wife probably secretly has a penchant
for tall dark warriors now here's the
thing who doesn't I was gonna say
especially when they're all beated up
like that now if she did get pregnant if
she had a little slip up I would all
honesty I would be like well I'm not
gonna talk to you for about three good
men don't really pay your man an F good
or she is already pissed off at you but
we're keeping the baby for sure baby I
want that baby like what would you do if
a man is like God tell me for real still
what would you do if she was like I do
you little brown James is like yeah
she's like I know what's going on keeps
lying my DMS asked me to come to the
hotel he's all these City set up a for
me put me up but just wants me to
[ __ ] go what should I do
would you and she's like I'm on birth
control should I go I'd say that I felt
like this and I'm just being honest this
LeBron it was long before he says it's
the million dollars it's LeBron Jillian
you know he's a billion dollar contract
Nike now don't forget basketball it's a
billion that's a house he'll forget
forget bathroom without 1000 million
dollars a lot of money thousand million
yes that's a thousand million yeah this
whole production company in Hollywood
now bring out what a billion dollars in
cash looks like for a second we've done
this several times just telling you how
exciting I would say this to her and I'd
be dead she's like he wants me to he
wants me to fly to Atlanta yeah you'd be
a matter what's up honey what are you
looking at oh babe do you know the Bron
James is do I know the LeBron King James
yeah I know the project on the king
yeah he's the greatest basketball player
period he's a freak ass I don't want to
get mad but what I'm not DM me like
crazy
he's been DMing you he he sent me a
picture of his dick let me let me see
that
it's let me just see it they call him
the king
yeah let me just see the pic but there
you go
yeah listen to me very carefully at soft
listen to me very carefully
did you say he's gonna be in LA he said
he wants to fly me to Atlanta okay I'll
listen to me very carefully
you're gonna fly to Atlanta now listen
let me uh get your jersey autographed
Amanda quiet I don't know how this far I
watched you to listen to what I'm saying
he flies me down there we do what not a
big deal
put your phone on record okay
he actually asked for that I study one
record our conversation over D you put
it in you get a good angle okay
and you allow him to get you pregnant
now let me finish now let me finish
there's someone didn't tell you though
what there's a few other teammates in
that hotel room that's where I draw the
goddamn line that's where I draw the
line because I don't know they said they
want to call it the lake show and it
starts on my ass that's not happening
that's not happening I will only allow
you to get pregnant by LeBron James you
keep the kid you don't tell him that you
have is kid and we raise that kid like
it's our own and when he questions later
heights 26 9 at 12 years old a beard
teeth I'll take him for a drive 12 go
have a little toward my peers are very
tall kid and I'll say aye aye well
that's that's well your
great-grandfather was a very good
basketball player swear I'm gonna say
yeah big nuts gin probably sometimes are
sometimes or not well you know I'm
saying though like counter the fat sack
I don't ride like you up like a flat
yeah baboon sector I've approached like
I've seen that thing that's just like
God right it looks like you know it
looks like a [ __ ] when you're
carrying a bag of money in those old
cartoons that's what it looks like
it's just like there's paying low like
it's like a leather purse now doing a
scene in acting class and I was naked
and its girl that's what does not to
look like that but like but like always
that way by the way I'm 20 I'm 23 in
acting school I had to do a nude scene
you had to get over far righty right I
hear a girl after this scene go like
this after when class got adjourned I
hear a girl go
but again I have done a scene naked and
it's so embarrassing right because it's
like you know your dick - I don't know
no you're naked so I hid a scrub though
I'm not doing that there's girl guys she
walks out you guys she'd knock you've
always said always have them bag you
nuts aha you've always had this if it's
a cold day it was called a my nut so
says so the reason your nuts go low is
it when it's telecontrol yeah not eight
I mean we all get out of it if it's cold
though my nuts are tight I got a tight
sack they're never tight bro you're
older you don't know yet grandfather
nuts
no nuts